[Music]
hello and welcome to the abbott
hematology hit series today on the art
and science of hematology morphology
platelet morphology
i am lexi krause of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation report your problem by
clicking on ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
today our presenter dan pelling will
share his decades-long expertise in
morphology
he will start with the art and science
of cellular straining principles
and its importance in the hematology
laboratory
then he will tie this together for a
review of unique patient cases that will
help listeners align automatic
hematology results
more
morphological findings and clinical
diagnosis
dan is the site manager for blood
sciences at st mary's hospital
paddington
which is part of northwest london
pathology based in the uk
he has extensive training in the
laboratory and has multiple degrees and
holds the highest specialist diploma in
hematology
and is qualified in forensic medicine
in his spare time he leads educational
efforts in the hematology community
he teaches at both undergraduate and
postgraduate level
is the lead tutor for the english
program stream of the multilingual
international education program
at ke he met image
and hold advisory positions at uk nequos
institute of biomedical sciences and the
european hematology association
here are today's learning objectives
observe a smear from normal blood
show platelet size and structure and the
natural variations seen in healthy
individuals
review smears that show abnormal
platelet morphology
talk through platelet case studies
including platelet cumping and
satellitism both in vitro effects
and under
excuse me an underestimated platelet
counts due to large or giant platelets
not being recognized
discuss disease states affecting the
size number and functionality of
platelets such as may hegelian anomaly
and bernard soulier syndrome
here are the required disclosures and
disclaimers for today's presentation
and it is now my pleasure to welcome dan
dan you may now begin your presentation
well thank you very much for the
introduction and i again i would like to
thank blood academy for the use of their
fantastic resource in being able to
deliver this webinar
this is the third webinar where we'll be
looking at platelets today
we won't be going into a great detail
about some of the clinical aspects of
platelet pathologies we will be looking
more at the morphology that presents
with platelets and also some of the
pitfalls and tips to overcoming some of
the pitfalls that we see in the
laboratory with some of our automated
analyzers
now of course
whenever we're looking at any blood film
i will state as i've stated many times
before we have to start from the
viewpoint of what is normal in order to
be able to identify what is abnormal
and
what i hope all of our participants who
have joined us today can see now
is a low power view of a blood
film we can see the red cells we can see
the white cells but dotted around in
between some of these red cells if we
look closely we can see some small
purple spots
let's zoom in
and as we zoom in on this blood film we
can see that these are in fact
purple colored platelets
now platelets are one of the we call
them cellular components of blood
and platelets usually are about one to
three micrometers in diameter
in fact if we look at some of the size
of these compared with the red cells on
this blood film from a normal healthy
person
we can see they're about a third maybe a
quarter to a third of the diameter of
most of the red cells
even in a normal healthy person there
will always be a small variation in
platelet size and in fact about five
percent maybe six percent of platelets
can be four micrometers or even five
micrometers in diameter but that's
that's probably the limit any more than
that then we might be looking at a
platelet pathology and we have to be
very wary of that and therefore approach
our blood film
in the standard manner to make sure that
we include all the considerations for
platelet numbers
and platelet appearance
platelets
i've got another name
they're called thrombocytes and in fact
that's where we get some of the
terminology for our disorders from from
the cytopenia thrombocytosis
but if we want to be really strict about
our terminology
then we really shouldn't be using those
words thrombosite
thrombocytopenia from the cytosis
because the word sight derives from the
greek word a cell
and these aren't cells platelets aren't
cells
they're fragments from the cytoplasm of
much larger cells than megakaryocytes
which we really don't see circulating in
the blood at all
however thrombocytosis from the
cytopenia thrombocytes as an alternative
name for platelets is so well ingrained
in hematology parlance that there's no
point in trying to be pedantic it's just
a
it's just an interesting point of
curiosity
so we can see our platelets dotted
around on this normal healthy film
and
they look to be quite a few
in fact the normal reference range for
the platelet counts is approximately 140
150 to 400 times 10 to the 9 per liter
of course different countries may have
different ways of reporting different
units
but but that is pretty much a very
standard way of reporting the number of
platelets
of course that covers 95 of the
population as well there will be a small
number of people who have a slightly
reduced platelet count but they're
perfectly healthy and some patients that
have a slightly higher platelet count
slightly above 400 they too are
absolutely perfectly healthy
but let's think more about the structure
of the platelet why does it appear as it
does
if we zoom in
and we lose a little bit of resolution
here as one
almost always does when we zoom in on
these pictures
we can see that the platelet
has a central's purple area maybe looks
a little bit granular
and maybe a slightly pale sort of halo
ring around it a blue looking appearance
these define the different regions of
the platelets
so the
inner area the area that looks purple a
stained purple purpley blue purpley red
using a standard ron minowski stain
is known as the granuloma or the
chromomere
and that's because it stains a color and
it's because of the granules in that
part of the platelets
and the area around the platelet that
looks slightly more pale slightly more
blue
is known as the hyalumia
let me just spend a few minutes looking
around this normal film we can see how
the platelets appear
with that small variation in size
off analyzers that would be maybe a
slightly higher
pdw platelet distribution width
but really nothing stands out as
particularly small or particularly large
or particularly discolored
and i use those three particular focal
top picks because that is what we're
going to be looking at small platelets
large platelets and discolored platelets
but with our technology today
we can get very accurate platelet counts
across a spectrum of platelet numbers
but we do have to be aware that
sometimes because of abnormalities in
platelet appearance the analyzers might
produce
falsely reduced platelet counts i'm
going to be talking quite a lot about
that as we move to our next slides
however as a rough rule of thumb
if we are looking at a blood film under
100 times oil immersion
and we are looking in the correct part
of the blood film
which is where the red cells are
slightly touching slightly overlapping
no big gaps between them
where we see the monolayer
then as a rough rule of thumb we should
see approximately seven to about 20
25 platelets per field on average
let's move to our next slide
i'll zoom right out on this side
macroscopically we can see there are
some big bits and clumps and it doesn't
look very smooth at all
if we zoom in on this slide
we can see that in fact there are these
large clumps
dotted around
the vast majority of medical laboratory
workers and physicians will be familiar
with the presence of platelet clumps
and we can see that some of these large
clumps when in fact they're so large
they can be seen by eye
some of them are slightly smaller
in fact some of them only comprise four
or five platelets together
now as we move around the slide we can
see this variation in platelet clumping
this is something that we have to be
very aware of
if we run a complete blood count or full
blood counts and we notice some
unexpected or unexplained low platelet
counts then it is important to urgently
review a blood film
if
as i say it's unexpected or unexplained
it doesn't fit with any of the patient
details or previous
counts that may have been performed on a
patient
it is important to check the full blood
count the actual sample for the presence
of clots or micro clots
if those aren't detected looking at the
film can often
show the presence of these microscopic
even though they're quite large here
microscopic platelet clumps
and what has happened the analyzer has
produced this falsely reduced platelet
count
but when we look at the blood film
we can see that in fact if all these
platelets were in fact disaggregated
then the platelet count would probably
be normal
it is very important to make sure that a
falsely reduced platelet count because
of the presence of platelet clumps is
removed from the results that are
reported
and that a comment is put in in its
place
platelet count may be reduced due to the
presence of platelet clumps however
platelet numbers appear adequate
they might even appear increased
sometimes we can get platelet clumps
present and the platelet count would
still be slightly reduced
however by providing that statement
platelet count of let's say 16
is reduced due to the presence of
platelet clumps
we're giving the physicians
the absolute minimum platelet count
that could possibly occur in these
patients under these situations in this
instance but also telling them that in
fact the platelet count is probably
normal because of these platelet clamps
when we notice platelet clumps it is
also very important to take a look at
the white count to make sure that the
white count hasn't been affected and
falsely increased by the presence of
these platelet clumps
when we look at the scatter plots on our
analyzers platelet clumps can usually be
quite easily identified by a very
specific discrete population
however if there are numerous platelet
clumps and a lot of them are quite large
that population can over spill into the
regions of your scatter plots where
gates are set for white cell
differentials
so it is important to make sure that you
look at the white cells to make sure
that they haven't been
forcefully increased
one thing to notice and it's quite
curious about these films when we see
platelet clumps is that often it just
looks like a bit of a homogeneous mess
almost like the platelets are stuck
together
when we see this clumping we often see
that a lot of the platelets are
degranulated part of this process of
clumping together has caused the
platelets to release their granules and
they appear more gray or more blue
so
a lot of the platelets can appear quite
pale
here's an example
it's part of a platelet here that has
lost most of its granular appearance
so it is important to look very
carefully
what actually causes platelet clumping
are we have we got patients who have
platelet clamps circulating around who
are walking out there in the public
no
platelet clumping is an in-vitro
phenomenon
and
more often than not
it's mediated by the presence of edta
which is the common anticoagulant we
nearly all of us use for our full blood
counts
the anticoagulant actually causes a
conformational change
in the
glycoprotein receptors on the surface of
the platelet
specifically it's the glycoprotein 2b 3a
receptor
and that actually causes the platelets
to become slightly activated and to
start clumping together
there are many methods that laboratories
use to try and remove this aggregation
as warming the sample
or maybe gently vortexing mixing the
sample for a minute or so
to mechanically disrupt the platelet
clumps
sometimes the addition of small amounts
of antibiotics such as amy casein can
cause the platelets to disaggregate
and sometimes the use of special tubes
that have magnesium sulfate in them as
their anticoagulant rather than edta can
be used
but more often than not laboratories
will ask for a citrated sample to come
up the type of sample that you'd use for
a clotting screen
that can work but i would say in my
experience 31 years in hematology it
really doesn't work very often and you
still see platelet clumps in situated
samples
but if you do use a situated sample to
try and determine an accurate platelet
count one important thing to remember is
that you must multiply the platelet
count by 1.1
to take into account the dilution effect
of the citrate that's present
[Music]
platelets can also be large platelets
can also be small
if platelets are particularly large even
just individually
then they may not actually be included
in the platelet counts on your analyzer
they may be so large that they fall
outside the threshold for including the
the entity within the platelet counts
and that's really what we're going to
look at uh for the rest of this
presentation
what's called the macrothrombocyte
and the pitfalls
if we look at this slide at slightly
lower power
we can see our platelets
immediately dotted around in between the
red cells it's a slightly thick part of
the film here but they're much more
visible
that's the first thing that strikes us
they seem to be larger
and in fact if we zoom in
we can see that some of these platelets
are almost the same size as a red cell
as we move around the slide the other
thing that strikes us
is that in fact there seem to be far
fewer platelets as well
okay we have two very large platelets
here in fact i wouldn't even call them
large i would call them giant platelets
and there we have a distinction
so i said to start with the majority of
platelets are one to three microns in
diameter
some will be a little bit bigger but
when platelets begin to get to the size
of five microns and six microns and so
forth
they're termed large platelets
when a platelet becomes the size of a
normal red cell so about seven microns
and above
they're termed giant platelets
and here we see
some normal sized platelets
some large platelets
and some giant platelets together on
this film
when we see this it is very important
for the microscopist to
assess the number of platelets because
even though the platelets are large and
on this example we're looking at here
the platelet count is slightly reduced
you can have large platelets and they're
completely normal platelet counts
large platelets they're all large but
the platelet count might
genuinely be about 250
but because the analyzer hasn't included
them in the platelet count the analyzer
might only have counted those platelets
falling within the normal size range so
it may have produced the platelet count
maybe of 60 or even 70 or even lower
it is crucially important to recognize
that to remove that incorrect
automated platelet accounts and perform
a manual platelet estimate from the film
[Music]
performing a manual platelet estimate
from the film is something that takes a
lot of practice
there are some rough rules of thumb that
can be followed out there
my personal
favorite way of producing a manual
platelet estimate from the film
is to find the part of the film that is
the correct part to review again the
monolayer where the red cells are just
touching or maybe slightly overlapping
where we can see a good amount of
central power in the red cells
and then under 100 times oil and it must
be 100 times oil lens
count the number of platelets in 10
consecutive fields
i then determine what the average per
field is from
that and multiply that value by
approximately
twenty thousand
and that will give me my rough estimate
when you look in textbooks some textbook
might say follow that procedure but use
fifteen thousand at the end
well in fact it's up to your local
procedure what you determine to be the
most accurate method but remember you're
only looking at a very small number of
fields really
if i'm performing a manual estimate i
might follow that procedure once and get
a result and then perform it again get a
result and take the average
from that
the key thing is to notice in the first
place that that painting account is
inaccurate
of course on the other side of the
spectrum we can have increased platelet
counts from the cytosis
but what we see here
is a blood film
from a patient with ion deficiency
thrombotizotosis
can
occur because of a genetic defect a
congenital defect
however
we see it most frequently as a reaction
a reactive thrombocytosis
to see a reactive thrombocytosis is
quite common in pulmonary conditions
not that
unusual in iron deficiency as well
although severe iron deficiency can
actually
result in the thrombocytopenia
but looking at this film here under a
similar magnification as some of our
other films
then we noticed straight away where we
can see far more
platelets dotted around
the platelet count in this particular
instance was about
about 500 550
so about 25 increased above the top of
the normal range
we can see again a slight variation in
size but the vast majority of these
platelets actually look normal in size
and look all fairly similar in sizes as
well
and that's what we tend to see when the
the marrow is responding appropriately
if the marrow is responding
appropriately to a condition where the
platelets are actually being
consumed or destroyed in the peripheral
circulation
then what we might see is actually an
increase in the variation of size of
platelets
so let's have a little bit of a recap
we know what the normal platelet should
look like we know what its morphology
should be
we know that it has a slightly granular
uh a central part to it those granules
are the alpha granules and the the dense
bodies
within that granuloma or chromomere
the it's the alpha granules that stain
up giving it this appearance and there
are many many more alpha granules within
that region than there are dense bodies
the alpha granules that stain up stain
the way they do because they contain a
lot of proteins different types of
proteins that are secreted and released
as part of the
platelets adhesion
activation and aggregation processes
there are far fewer dense bodies within
that central region the dense bodies
generally contain they contain quite a
lot of uh
components however they are responsible
for storing
adp
atp
calcium and magnesium and of course all
important parts of the hemostatic
process
but even in conditions of abnormal size
we can see
fairly normal morphology
and even if you do have abnormally sized
platelets that doesn't always mean that
they are dysfunctional so you may have
completely normal hemostatic processes
however as the microscopist looking at
the blood film and thinking oh these
platelets are large that should
automatically trigger you to think about
what could this be do i need to look for
any other signs to help me narrow down
what's going on here
well yes and this is one perfect
example so there are a group of
disorders the macro thrombocytopenias
so we see macro large platelets and
reduced platelets
and then just the sort of normal number
macrocytic platelet conditions
one set of conditions
is the
myh9 conditions
now in times gone by we would have
called these
hegelian anomaly
sebastian syndrome
fechner syndrome
epstein syndrome
and possibly even ekstein syndrome as
well
and they were all thought to be
completely separate disorders
but as technology has allowed us to
investigate these more thoroughly we now
know that they are part of a spectrum of
one complete disorder known as the
myh9 disorders
it's a mutation in the myosin heavy
chain 9
that results in macro thrombocytes large
platelets and giant platelets
and in
this particular disorder may hegelian
anomaly the presence of white cell
inclusions
whenever my staff come and ask me to
look an unexpected low platelet count
and i notice large platelets or large
platelets but in fact it's just a normal
platelet count one of the first things i
do look at the neutrophils to see if i
can identify any pale grey pale blue
inclusions
usually towards the periphery of the
neutrophil
because if i can and they can be very
subtle
you have to look carefully
if i can then i think i know what i'm
looking at this is most likely a may
hegelian anomaly
and i check the automated count against
the count that i think
should be coming from the blood film
see these playable bodies
double check that the platelet count is
going out correctly and then have a
discussion with the physicians
may haggling anomaly isn't the only
anomaly that we see with these large
plates as i mentioned
if i scroll out to a low magnification
on this film then we again can see
immediately that we have a a fairly
decent number of platelets probably
slightly on the low side but they are
nearly all of them are large again
here we have one that's a giant platelet
it's virtually the same size as the red
cells
and here it's really emphasized the
different zones within the platelets
this is a condition called bernat
soulier syndrome which results from
mutation in one of the uh
which results in a
mutation in one of the glycoproteins on
the surface of the platelets the
glycoprotein 1b
or the 1b95 complex
and as i said right at the beginning
we're not going to look at these
specific disorders in depth what we're
really doing is emphasizing here the
need to be aware that a lot of these
platelets
may well not have been included in the
automated platelet counts
and the analyzer could easily have
produced a platelet count of
probably about
15 20 maybe 25 on this patient
and looking at it
looking at this film now we know that in
fact it's far higher than that
thank you
in the previous webinar with adverts
from labyrinths we did look at red cells
and one of the things we spoke about is
when you're looking at a blood film it's
very important to identify the presence
of red cell fragments well linking that
in with today's webinar when you have
this unexpected or unexplained low
platelet count and you are urgently
looking at a blood film
it is so important to remember to look
for some key features
and that's the presence of clumps which
we've looked at
the presence of platelet satellitism
when platelets are
bound to the outside of
neutrophils it's also very important for
the presence of
blasts because you may be looking at a
new hematological neoplasm
also to look for the presence of
malarial parasites within the red cells
as not uncommonly malaria can actually
be picked up for the first time because
you're looking at a blood film due to
the presence of unexpected or
unexplained lower platelets
but it is ultra important to look for
the presence of red cell fragments
because the combination of red cell
fragments and low platelets
can indicate some very very emergent
diseases
these are usually the thrombotic
microangiopathies
microangiopathic hemolytic anemias
and what we see here
is a thrombotic microangiopathy
and
even at this power we can see the red
cells don't look normal a lot of them
look like they've been broken up and
smashed or cheese wired or stripped or
cut in half and they look very angular
and pointy
but remembering that we're approaching
our blood film in the standard
manner and not forgetting our platelets
we also notice
in fact there are very few platelets
because we know what they look like now
whether they're large
or normal
we know what they should look like we
we can't see any
well just maybe one or two dotted around
very low number
this combination
actually heralds
in this particular case it was a post
bone marrow transplant thrombotic
microangiopathy
but it looks very very similar to
condition called
ttp
thrombotic from the cytopenic purpura
incredibly urgent condition patients can
actually succumb to this very very
quickly
we're talking a matter of hours
sometimes
so that's not to scare anyone but it is
to be realistic and to emphasize the
importance of checking out low play
fifths
so i would estimate the platelet count
probably in this patient to be
it would be less less than 20 i would
say
and what is quite interesting is that
platelet count doesn't always correlate
with bleeding phenotype
so in fact you can have a very high
platelet counts and have a bleeding
disorder because the platelets might be
dysfunctional
it is not particularly usual for
patients to to bleed if their platelet
counts above 50
between 50 and 20 they may have some
sort of
bleeding presentation but patients
really only start to present with a
bleeding anomaly
if if they've got normal platelets but
their platelet count is
less than about 30
20 30.
this patient had a lot of other things
going on because we can see how jolly
bodies but really we're just focusing on
platelets today
this slider before i go back and recap
some other points
um is very important because as i
mentioned if you're looking at a film
because of unexpected unexplainable
platelets
the clinical team might not have
considered a travel history and you
might pick up malaria
malaria can be quite uh it can be quite
tricky
to identify
however depending upon the experience of
the microscopist then it's usually
identifiable as present from thick films
and then species identification from
thin films
but what can look quite similar to
malaria is a condition called babesia
young stages the trophizoids can look
very similar
although the trophozoites are generally
a lot smaller but the reason this slide
is included in today's webinar is
because unlike in malaria
the bezier parasites
are also extra erythrocytic malaria you
will see inside the red cell
the bezier you will see inside the red
cell but also outside the red cell on
the blood film between the red cells
and they can look like platelets
and babesia parasites can sometimes
clump together
and look like platelet clumps
so it is very important to know
the cause or the clinical details behind
a patient presenting
with unexplained
low platelets
so there are a number of conditions as
well
where the granulation doesn't look
correct in platelets
they can have vacuoles
they can have gaps they can have large
plates large granules big big granules
and those have
separate conditions themselves so we
have conditions such as uh
paris truestone or jacobson syndrome
where we see large platelets but with
abnormal granulation large platelets
abnormal granulation sometimes a big
just a few big red granules within
within the platelet itself
but we see abnormal platelets
depending upon your patient cohort
to this degree large platelets small
platelets
this granular platelets
in the myeloproliferative neoplasms
the myelodysplastic syndromes and the
overlap syndromes the myelodysplastic
myeloproliferative neoplasm overlap
syndromes
and so that course includes
polycythemia vera
essential thrombocythemia
myelofibrosis primary myelofibrosis
and chronic myeloid leukemia
because of the overlap it can also this
sort of thrombocyte appearance platelet
appearance can also appear in atypical
chronic myeloid leukemia
and in the chronic myelomonocytic
leukemias as well
it does emphasize the need to look at
that whole bigger picture when you're
approaching your slide remember don't
just focus on the platelets if they
don't look abnormal or don't just focus
on the white cells if they look abnormal
think about everything together
but this is an essential thrombocythemia
patient
and again if we go to roughly the same
magnification as we've looked at in our
other slides we can see that there is a
vastly increased number of platelets
this platelet count is probably up
around the
900 1000 mark
as we zoom in we can see that there they
are abnormally granule granulated
and with quite a significant variation
in size
the number of platelets that are that
large or even giant
is not sufficiently high to have falsely
reduced the platelet count
the majority of platelets do look within
that region where they would have been
counted by the analyzer
but one of the things we do have to be
aware of is that if some platelets are
very agranular
or very sort of high poco angular or
even a granular
they may not have actually been included
these are almost like platelet fragments
a hypogranulo or a granular fragments
cytoplasm from the mega carrier sites
uh
one other
tip pitfall or thing to be aware of in
the laboratory
is that what looks like a platelet might
not always be a platelet
what i've put up here is a picture of a
t-cell pro-lymphocytic leukemia because
it really highlights this specific point
i'm trying to get to now
which is sometimes you can have white
cells with ragged cytoplasm
or with a cytoplasmic blebs
these cells that i'm showing here are
white cells
they're t-cell pro-lymphocytes
and classically
they demonstrate these cytoplasmic blebs
in some white cell conditions that have
these blebs
such as t-cell proline acidic leukemia
or even megakaryoblastic leukemia
these blebs can actually break off the
red cells and start freely circulating
there are some other myeloid leukemias
not just the megacarrier leukemias where
this can happen as well especially if
the blasts
and the blast population
is quite fragile
what we see then are these pale blue
bits of cytoplasm
circulating
which may be detected and counted by the
analyzed as platelets
the genuine platelet count in this
patient was very very low
however
some of these pale blue
hypogranular or a granular
entities
that are circulating are in fact
cytoplasmic fragments they're not
platelets
so we have to be very aware of a falsely
elevated platelet count coming off an
automated platform
when we know from the morphology
that there are these blebs and
cytoplasmic fragments
presence
again if this were the case we would go
to the correct part of the film and try
to attempt a genuine platelet estimate
from the film
using whatever is your agreed local
method
so i'm going to move between two
separate films that we've looked at
before now just to emphasize so almost
as if we're looking at
two films like that
normal and macrocytic
huh
so moving backwards and forwards just a
few times there
you begin to see and get your eye in on
the difference in platelet size the
increased mpv mean platelet volume and
four
most normal healthy
subjects
the mpv or the mean platelet volume will
rest somewhere between about seven and
ten maybe seven and twelve femtoly
femtoliters
when you begin to get above that 12.5 or
13s maybe even up to the 20 mark
that's when you're looking at the macro
thrombocytes
and that's when you have to consider the
automated platelet counts
and the presence of other inclusions
such as
as we looked at in our may hegelian case
the presence of these pale blue gray
inclusions in the neutrophils
many people will refer to these as
doly bodies they're not true doli bodies
they're doley-like bodies they have a
slightly different uh
slightly different appearance in when
you look at them than their ultra
structure
but to recognize their presence and to
comment on them is the most important
thing
i mentioned earlier on
that some of the platelets may be
very hypogranular and
or even a granular
and that's when we have to consider
whether they're blast fragments or blebs
from the cytoplasm of other white cells
but we do have a condition called grey
platelet syndrome
and that's due to the lack of alpha
granules that can be seen on a
romanovsky stained film
those conditions can also result in
analyzer producing a forcefully reduced
platelet count because some analyzers
that actually use
laser
light and and angle scatter to determine
the size and granularity of an entity in
order to classify it as a platelet
won't have that granularity to measure
in gray platelet syndrome so it may not
include what is a platelet
in the final plate that counts
because those platelets in gray platelet
syndrome
have lost their alpha granules yes they
are dysfunctional they don't work
properly and the low platelet count and
can probably
falsely reduce platelet account can be
aligned with the clinical history or
examination history in order to start
working towards diagnosis
but what that does is
mentioning gray platelet syndrome is
bringing everything sort of together
um about the large platelets and the
discolored platelets is
into one sort of picture to say these
are the things that you need to consider
but what i will end up with
is talking about
the other end of the spectrum the very
small platelets
there are some conditions they are rare
where the platelet number it might be
normal it might be reduced platinum
number um
can fall within any range really
but the platelets all look very small
less than one micrometer sometimes 0.5
sometimes just almost like a little pin
prick between the red cells
this can be associated with just a very
s
a small a handful of conditions
but one of the ones that is uh referred
to the most in the textbooks is wiscot
aldrich syndrome
that combines autoimmune sort of uh
processes eczema
um
and it's due to a gene mutation the wasp
gene mutation
that's characterized by might
he's just looking for the falsely
reduced platelet count off the analyzer
because of large platelets be aware of
the clinical history a young child
eczema autoimmune history and a very
small numerous yet very small platelets
on the blood film could you be looking
at a wisconsin syndrome child
very closely related to whisker aldrich
syndrome because of the underlying
molecular processes in the mutation
is x-linked thrombocytopenia and
x-linked neutropenia
they do also present
with small platelets
so be aware of all the platelet ranges
be aware of the platelet granularity
um be aware of other inclusions in white
cells not just dody-like bodies in
neutrophils but maybe other large
inclusions
in in neutrophils and make monocytes and
lymphocytes that could indicate the
shedding
syndrome for example which can be
associated with thrombocytopenia and a
variation
in in platelet size
and try and put everything together
bring it all together that bigger
picture
so
when we approached our film and we use
our standard approach to make sure we
don't miss out one of the lineages we
look at the red cells we look at the
white cells we look at the platelets
platelets are very often
the least remarkable lineage to comment
on
usually we're looking at blood films
because of red cell abnormalities or
or whites are abnormalities when we're
looking at platelets it's usually
because it's unexpectedly low
or it's low and we can't explain it with
clinical history
but occasionally you will get the very
interesting case go through
where they're large
they're dis granular they're
particularly small
and that's when you think okay i might
have something interesting going on here
i need to investigate it in a little bit
more depth in order to drive that
diagnosis forward whittle it down at
least
it is a very large topic and if you go
to the textbooks or you go to some of
the reputable websites
there will be tables with lists of
various conditions
that are associated with large platelets
or small platelets
or platelet abnormal platelet
granularity
and it will talk about
scot syndrome storm walking syndrome
york syndrome
harris syndrome um
congenital a megacarrier city
thrombocytopenia
thrombocytopenia associated with radio
ulnar synostosis
there's an awful lot to remember of more
mutations are being identified almost on
a on a monthly basis that are associated
with thrombocytopenia or with the
presence of large platelets
so
it's
it's not something that
you can look at and you can learn but
it's very interesting topic to make sure
that you stay abreast of
when that patient comes in who may have
bruising may have bleeding
or may just be having a regular checkup
and that could be how you pick it up
so this has been
quite
a brief tour of the topic i hope you've
enjoyed this as an introduction and i'm
sure that in the coming few months
we will be looking at other topics with
abbott and with lab roots
i will end this session now
we do have time for questions and
answers and be more than happy to take
some questions and provide the answers
where i can
thank you very much
thank you dan and we appreciate your
time today and all of the valuable
information you have presented for our
audience we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
but before we answer your questions from
the audience we would like to
acknowledge the support of the blood
academy center for hematology education
by providing the blood film images that
this webinar is based on
please visit the center at
www.bloodhyphenacademy.com
if you are interested in learning more
so dan let's go ahead and move on to our
questions the first question that we
have for you is
why do platelet numbers increase with
iron deficiency
well thank you yes that is that is very
good question and it is something that
we frequently see
in the laboratory
not least because iron deficiency is is
a very common condition
um across the globe
there have been many studies into this
and and it was thought that it was a
reactive thrombocytosis
that was driven by cytokines
and sort of the bone marrow environment
being triggered to create more
megakaryocytes and to release more
platelets
but studies have shown that it may be
not
that easy to determine why we do see
increased numbers of platelets in iron
deficiency
now
megakaryocytes
are the main cells from which platelets
are derived and about one thousand to
three thousand platelets per normal
megacarrier site
but even in the presence of
cytokines such as interleukin-6 which we
see increased in inflammatory conditions
it doesn't seem to be a direct collect
connection between
that cytokine level and the number of
platelets
now
one could argue that
one cause of iron deficiency is bleeding
occult bleeding or maybe
some other sort of
gastrointestinal bleeding
and through evolution we have some as
yet to be determined mechanism that
increases our platelet count to try and
stop that bleeding
so we can see why there might be a an
increased platelet count in iron
deficiency
but
really
no one's really figured out quite
how that happens yet
great thank you so much dan
one of our questions is actually a
recommendation from you
do you recommend to draw blood samples
with heparin or citrate for plt clump
cases
okay so this has been a thorny question
for everybody working in hematology labs
for many years
now
historically
we have said in many areas if you see
platelet clumping in edta
request a situated count
and run that count and then correct it
for the dilution factor by multiplying
it by 1.1
but
i've been practicing hematology for 31
years
and i would say the vast majority of
times a citrated platelet count has not
resolved the issue of edta induced
platelet clumping
we often see plate that comes just as
frequently in those
citrated samples
we have recently started looking at
heparinized samples because with heparin
eye samples you don't have to correct
for the dilution factor
and we do see a slight improvement
i.e a reduction in the number and size
of platelet clumps that we see
but really if if someone has got quite a
strong auto antibody
they are going to experience platelet
clumping with almost any type of
anticoagulant
i would say
in the old days before edta was used we
used to use magnesium sulfate as an
anticoagulant and one does not see
platelet clumping with magnesium sulfate
as an anticoagulant so that could be
something that people might wish to
explore
also
slight addition of amica sin the
antibiotic to disaggregate platelets or
gentle vortexing
there are many methods out there and one
has to see what works best
at the moment i would say when i ask
well when i ask my laboratory staff to
request a repeat i ask them to request
both a situated sample and a heparinized
example
i tend to sit on the fence about that
well thank you so much stanford uh for
your recommendation and looks like we've
got time for one more question
so what is the relationship between
kawasaki disease and thrombocytosis
kawasaki disease and thrombocytosis
okay um that would be a question that i
would have to look into it in a little
bit more depth
um
really uh
again there could be a reactive
component to it um quite a deep reactive
component to to kawasaki disease that
may be driving
some sort of thrombocytosis um
but uh i think that that is a sort of
question really that
it really takes time to think about um
and get back um to to the person who's
asked that question what i would say
is for anyone who who may be listening
and is not familiar with kawasaki
disease
we can see extremely high plate that
counts in kawasaki disease
so
what is driving the platelet count the
thrombocytosis to that extreme level
there are papers out there it's not
particularly clear again
what really we wanted to to focus on
today was was not necessarily
the platelet count
correlation with disease states because
it can be
many fold this was more looking at some
of those morphological
features that we can see on platelets
and how they can trip us up sometimes or
even indicate what disease state we
might be looking at
as we know in hematology
in almost every case the exceptions
prove the rule
so really looking at looking at that the
platelet count and those disease states
such as kawasaki where it is so high or
can be so high um
it really is is probably another topic
in its own right another webinar in its
own right it is a very good question
though
well we would look forward to having you
back for that one
so dan we're gonna
we're gonna keep you on for actually one
more question and here's a really good
one that just came in from the audience
so are there any cases in which we will
see megakaryocytes or
megachiroblasts in the peripheral blood
and what would be the cause for that
yes there are some states where we can
see uh megakaryocytes in the peripheral
blood on mega carrier blasts um
and also bare megakaryocyte nuclei
now we
megakaryoblastic leukemias
under the
the previous fab classification
classified as m7
one can see mega carrier blasts
circulating bear in mind that they are
likely to be in low numbers
but they are quite distinctive with
quite a high nuclear cytoplasmic ratio
and frequently with cytoplasmic blebbing
we do see some
very sort of infantile leukemias
certainly with translocations between
chromosome 1 and 22 which often have a
mega carrier blastic component to them
as well
so we can see them in those conditions
where it's driven by a malignancy
in its own right
but when the bone marrow is under stress
whether that's through extreme uh
sort of infection or infiltration maybe
infiltration from some other
carcinoma site
then we can see a lot of the bone marrow
components spilling out and over into
the peripheral blood megakaryocytes
being one of those
because megakaryocytes have quite that
sort of voluminous cytoplasm that can
frequently be stripped
um from them in the process of moving
from the marrow environment to the
peripheral blood which sometimes leaves
us with circulating bare megakaryocyte
nuclei
which are again are quite distinctive
with their lumps and their folds and
their clefts as the nuclei have folded
on one another so that that marrow
stress
the marrow stress whether through
infection or infiltration or narrow
stress can also be through direct
malignancy such as myelofibrosis
but we can see megakaryocyte fragments
and the occasional bare megacares like
nucleus or small megacarrier site in
fact circulating in essential form
cythemia and also
myelofibrosis as well
so quite a few conditions it's certainly
abnormal and it is the signal for you to
stop and think about what might be going
on
great thank you so much dan
we want to you know thank you again for
your informative presentation do you
have any final comments for our audience
before we let you go
i i do have uh one final comment uh
really and that is
and this is a thread throughout all of
the the webinars really
is that it's it's important to step back
and take in the entire picture even when
you're looking at platelets
sometimes
they're off they're overlooked because
they're not very exciting they're quite
small but they can tell you a lot about
what is going on reactive wise or
malignancy wise
but the one of the biggest problems we
see
across the globe
are misreported platelet counts
and that is because we can often be
unaware that large platelets
or gray platelets
might not be counted by our analyzers
fantastic though they are these days
and it's our job to act as those
gatekeepers when we're looking at the
blood film to say
no
this time the analyzer's not right
and me as the scientist i'm going to
correct it and
and give out a more accurate platelet
estimate from the blood film
so it's looking at it from that
laboratory position and being aware of
what can go wrong as well that is so
important and i hope that is really one
of the key things that that our audience
has taken away from today
thank you again dan for your time today
and your important information excuse me
and your important and informative
presentation we would also like to thank
our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting question
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time bye bye everyone
you